das sind nur wohl zu spät sie der
armenier als armutszeugnis wenn ich
nicht warum er so ein schwein das
schwein sein darf hat wirklich schein
mit der schnauze in der erde wühlen über
eine wiese rennen von den 1,4 millionen
schweizer schweinen dürfen dass nur
wenige dieser film erzählt vom
schweinemäster oliver hess und seiner
familie von seiner vision den tieren
trotz massenhaltung möglichst viel
auslauf frische luft und vor allem würde
zu geben
von einem schweinemäster der eine tier
fabrik auf um so die schweinehaltung zu
revolutionieren
vier jahre waren wir mit der kamera
dabei vier jahre in denen einiges anders
kam als erwartet
[Musik]
unsere geschichte beginnt im november
2015 die wenigen wochen alten ferkel
kämpfen um ihr futter ein ganz
gewöhnlicher morgen im luzernischen
mohsen im stall von oliver esther und
anouk es der schweinestall ist ein
großbetrieb 1800 mastschweine pro jahr
200 mutter sei den hof hat familie hess
2012 gekauft mit einem darlehen
[Musik]
da es jetzt klappen
zuerst mal hier reingekommen ist vor
drei jahren was war deine gedanken also
ist eine klage hatte mir ein linkshänder
beck steht im stau
und seither hat er seine mission er will
glücklichere schweine
dafür hat er im stall bereits einiges
verändert aber das reicht noch lange
nicht er will den betrieb komplett
umbauen
das brauche allerdings zeit und geld
angeschafft weil das für mich wirklich
sehr schlimm sich zum alltag wie die
tierart beraten und sozusagen hat die
ganz motivation geben wird so wirtz
wache dass das mit chancen hände mal
wirklich bitte serie bis zwei andere mal
nachgerechnet
das fast nie zum aushalten als vor allem
mit dem aussehen ich greife ich immer
machen halt und probieren dass ihre
abgeschalteten hat das gefühl das sind
auch mit ihr weil es gar nicht machen
der maststall hier ist alles noch so wie
oliver hess den hof übernommen hat und
da sind wir interessiert didier ya
einspringen wo weiter ist auch
erstligist sc alles ist im erlaubten
rahmen auch der voll spalten boden der
wurde erst 2018 verboten
trotzdem sind das für oliver hess
schlimme zustände die einen totalumbau
erfordern würden
diese schweine sind etwa drei monate alt
werden mit sieben monaten geschlachtet
liegen dann rund 110 kilogramm und
wahrte so bis märz
[Applaus]
das war mir immer wichtig sei aber dass
das direkt muss gucken hier richtig für
moskau seit jahrtausenden dient das
schwein den menschen als
fleischlieferant doch für oliver es ist
ein schwein mehr
es hat bedürfnisse ähnlich denen der
wildsau es möchte in der erde wühlen
nachrichten suchen hier ist die
empfindliche schnauze dem ammoniak
ausgesetzt dass aus ihrem urin und kot
entsteht
[Musik]
er hat sich hoch verschuldet um einen
hof zu kaufen den er radikal verändern
kann
ende 2015 sind die pläne schon sehr
konkret das modell eines auslauf geheges
steht und wie bin ich sicher dass wieder
alle 15 sind oliver hess sucht
investoren um seine ideen zu realisieren
zwei millionen franken interessiert sind
heute der fleischverarbeiter mit ghana
und ein berufskollege so einige pläne
sind die musen bereits umgesetzt nämlich
im stall mutter sei sie haben eine
abgetrennte toiletten bucht und im
liegebereich 1 strahlt und bodenheizung
schon wenige tage nach dem absetzen der
ferkel kommt die brust bei schweinen
auch branche genannt der richtige
zeitpunkt für die künstliche besamung
doch die natur wird nicht ganz aus
gesperrt es kommt ein echter ebert zum
einsatz allerdings nur mit seiner nase
das blut der mutter säule kommt trotzdem
in wallung wenn er auf seinem
ferngesteuerten wagen vorbei fährt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da sollte eigentlich wieder hoch
zum glück ja man könnte eigentlich auch
sagen sofort alle tiere freilassen oder
schlachten nicht länger leiden lassen
stattdessen kaufen warum das jeweils
dieses problem nicht löst jedes jahr in
der schweiz 2 5 millionen schweine und
wenn ich jetzt sage also getötet einem
krieg die wahrheit auf 2,5 millionen
schweine importiert mehr allzu viel
so also flüssig ist doch nur dass man
auch ohne alternative zum sie hoffte
zwei monate später oliver hess ist
unterwegs um für sein projekt zu werben
für seine vision von freilaufenden
wiesen schweinen beim akku treff 2016
busswil
wie dolly und gehörte zu der außer von
der manager trotz der relativen ich
glaube so eine kindliche neugier baute
der gelernte offsetdrucker oliver es
liebte schon immer das fast unmögliche
2004 baute er das größte baum aus der
schweiz um einen liebenden baum herum
bändigen
tiere und natur
davon waren es deren oliver es bereits
2008 begeistert sie bewirtschaften eine
alpin wallis ab 2009 bereits mit baby
anouk
[Musik]
als herdenschutz beauftragter des bundes
machte oliver hess 2010 seinem ärger
gegenüber 10 vor 10 luft rote zahlen
dass ich trotz betrieben ich eine junge
familie das geld wirklich unzufrieden
wird oliver hess als er später auf einem
mastbetrieb die übliche schweinehaltung
hautnah kennen lernt seitdem lässt in
der gedanke an glücklichere schweine
nicht mehr los zurück ins luzernische
zum stall in moosen im januar 2016
drinnen geht der alltag des
schweinemastbetriebes weiter für die
ganze familie
zwei tage alt und schon ein unfall die
muttersau hat sich wohl versehentlich
auf ihr fertige legt 300 kilogramm tun
wie goethe und luther sagen und ich
würde es aber töten
und wenn sie jetzt noch die mutter oft
stress ist gelernte landwirtin jeden
tages im stall auch jetzt noch wo sie im
achten monat schwanger ist
[Musik]
ein gutes jahr später es ist mai 2017
familie hesses gewachsen und tochter
vivien ist das was hier auch der rest
der familie ist schweineschnitzel der
traum von einer artgerechten
schweinehaltung ist weiterhin aktuell
inklusive auslauf auf die weide in der
computeranimation ist alles schon
realität
das ist massiv höhere hat dass man die
luft damit immer nach es kommt auf die
koppel
dort waren wir relativ kurz die zentrale
finanziere
bisher ist von den großen zukunftsplänen
auf dem hof nichts zu sehen noch immer
fristen die tiere ihr dasein ohne
auslauf ins freie
aber oliver hess ist weiter unermüdlich
daran seine pläne von einer besseren
schweinehaltung umzusetzen
gegen alle widerstände und mit
notfallplan
wenn sie trotz aller schwierigkeiten hat
oliver hess investoren gefunden die an
seine idee der wiesn schweine glauben
millionen franken zu
das ist natürlich nicht dass der mann
erhöhte betrag weil nebenan im stall
läuft die vorbereitung zu kastrieren
esther s verabreicht den männlichen
ferkeln zuvor ein schmerzmedikament
danach wird die vollnarkose eingeleitet
das narkosemittel strömt aus der maske
in die schnauze nicht damit
die ferkel erholte sich schnell von dem
eingriff schon nach wenigen minuten
stehen die meisten wieder und sonst
helfen die geschwister nach
ein halbes jahr später dezember 2017
oliver hess ist unterwegs nach basel zum
hauptsitz mit group soll ein vertrag
unterzeichnet werden
der vertrag garantiert ihm die abnahme
seiner zukünftigen wiesen schweine was
wir unterzeichnen wenn die auflagen
vorhaben bleibt aber ja
[Musik]
dieses pilotprojekt das
leuchtturm-projekt er hat sehr viel
innovative ideen hat wie sehr weit wir
lassen die argumente mehr als film bevor
hoffen
der vertrag sichert die abnahme des
fleisches für oliver ist ein meilenstein
aber etwas entscheidendes fehlt noch ich
hoffe dass der kanton und behörden
gemeldet
und dann hoffen dass man nicht schwimmt
wie es vor dem start bringen
[Musik]
wenige monate später der schock seine
schweine müssen im stall bleiben
sein traum ist geplatzt
die behörden verweigern die
baugenehmigung der umbau wird vom kanton
als ersatzneubau eingestuft darum
verbiete das raumplanungsgesetz eine
ausweitung des stalles er als
gewerbebetrieb gilt
ist ja mal extrem schwierig hat sich
dank extrem schwierig ich habe so eine
zahl die treue versprochen wir frei
jeder kommt es kann jetzt dass das ist
das ist leben kommen
der hof ist verkauft ebenso das wohnhaus
nebenan das kapitel mohsen ist für
familie es jetzt zu ende und eine
schlechte bewegung er doch oliver es
wäre nicht oliver hess wenn er keinen
ausweg vorgesehen hätte im vertrag mit
coop ist eine option offen gehalten das
projekt erwiesen schweine muss nicht
zwingend in moosen umgesetzt werden weil
mahlzeit erwähnt die befreiung erwarten
die zehn jahren kam für physio auf ramos
einmal entschieden das muss man der
familie vom handel buchverkäufer
realisieren
wenige monate später im oktober 2008
zehn der brück hof in schüpfheim ist im
umbau hier soll die idee von den wiesen
schweinen erstmals umgesetzt werden
oliver es ist jetzt nicht mehr
schweinemäster sondern eine art
systemanbieter letzter testlauf mit den
technikern bevor die echten schweine
raus dürfen viel digitale technik und
automatisation sollen den schweinen ein
artgerechtes leben bieten sensoren
erkennen ob alle schweine wieder im
stahl sind dann kann die nächste gruppe
in den auslauf jede schweinegruppe hat
ihren eigenen ruf turm dann wissen die
tiere dass sie wieder in den stall
kommen sollen
denn es gibt futter so die theorie ich
bin sehr gespannt bis jeder weiß ganz
sicher dass alle die das machen
der investor ire
gespannt ist auch franz studer
er ist der hofbesitzer und will das
leben seiner jährlich 1000 mastschweine
verbessern
dann ist es soweit zum ersten mal öffnet
sich für die schweine das tor zum ersten
mal haben sie eine große fläche mit viel
material zu wühlen
[Musik]
schweine im besten teenie-alter
neugierig und quicklebendig
[Musik]
nur anzüge in wiederum ein halbes jahr
später
märz 2009 10 jetzt ist auch der auslauf
auf die wiese fertig die schweine dürfen
gruppenweise zweimal täglich für je eine
stunde ins grüne
[Musik]
der pool reizt noch nicht dagegen sind
die holzschnitzel sehr beliebt da sie
nach wald riechen und mit maiskörnern
versetzt sind was gefällt
[Musik]
diese ablenkung ist wichtig denn sonst
würden die schweine die wiese zu
erfüllen
diese ist zusätzlich mit einer matte im
boden geschützt
der ton ruft zum futtertrog die schweine
haben schnell gelernt
dieses system hat oliver hess
ausgetüftelt wenn viele bauern es
übernehmen kann er seine
entwicklungskosten vielleicht wieder
hereinholen
darauf ist er dringend angewiesen die
von ihm gegründete wiesen schwein ag
zahlt ihm nur einen kleinen lohn aber er
verdient mit wenn das fleisch unter
seinem markennamen verkauft wird
oliver hess findet dass das fleisch
seiner schweine sehr gut schmeckt und
hofft auf viele ähnlich denkende
konsumenten zum wohl der fleisch esse
aber auch der schweine moment brauche
bist eiligen aus extra optimieren wie
man sie noch nie mehr flanken aber das
ist unheimlich schön
diese schweine haben schwein zwar werden
auch sie in einigen monaten geschlachtet
aber sie hatten ein leben in würde
[Musik]